ihr könnt ja mal in die kommentare
schreiben welche farbe hat meine
unterhose gerade bin gespannt was genau
und jetzt bekommen beim ein video
ich muss erst mal sagen das gab's noch
nie ich habe ein paar wir haben gerade
donnerstag ich habe heute einfach zwei
videos an einem tag gedreht und es kam
in den netzen drei tagen jeden tag ein
video als er was ist los weil dafür erst
mal bitte kurz sein applaus danke schön
und ich weiß absolut nicht was in meinen
harmlos ist die stehen einfach nur star
noch da noch da unten einfach wieder
runter und wieder was denn es geht um
die haare da kann man sich mal aufregen
also beachtet heute bitte nicht meine
haare
ich habe mich gerade mal ein bisschen
umgeschaut und zwar was kann ich machen
neues junges mädchen thema und bin da
unter meinem letzten video das muss man
kurz gucken aber ich den kommentar mal
vorlesen also unter beim letzten jungs
mädchen zimmer rohde geschrieben video
idee die jungs und mädchen
unterschiedlich handeln wenn sie
jemanden mögen ich habe es jetzt einfach
auf center pcs verpasst ich hab es ist
einfach so interpretiert wie halt jungs
und mädchen verschiedenen reagieren oder
sich verschieden verhalten wenn sie sich
verliebt haben
juni willst du was verliebte mich
schreibe ich habe dich natürlich nur
spaß genau auf jeden fall habe ich euch
aufs netzel aufgefordert leute schicken
bitte eine menge zu wie sie das bei euch
auch an die jungen steve erhaltet ihr
euch an die mädels wie verhaltet ihr
euch ich hab da mal durchgeschaut ich
hatte ohne spaß bis in 2000 netz
bekommen
das problem beide nur 1967 netz fahren
wirklich für mädchen wo ich mich frage
ich kann ja bei youtube schauen wie viel
prozent von meinen zuschauern weiblich
wie viele männlich und zwar habe ich 60
bin weiblich 40 prozent männlich sucht
sich die wir alle keine snaps also an
die jungs jetzt beim nächsten mal
wünsche ich mir ein bisschen mehr
präsenz von euch weil dann muss ich mich
nicht immer alle selber überlegen so
dass ich ja am besten fahren habe ich
natürlich die screenshot wir gehen
zusammen durch und durch viel spaß bei
15.000 gibt es nicht die jungs mädchen
video ist
jackson ab dienstag wenn ihr auch mal
was schicken world glaub ich hab schon
wieder viel zu lange gelagert
die erste nachricht wenn ein mädchen
einen jungen liebst ob sie ihn so krass
dass die sogar weiß was eine ungewisse
erträgt einfach alles und die sucht
komplizinnen die noch mal über ihn
herausfinden von 155 was ich dazu sagen
kann ich bin ja nicht blöd ich weiß ja
dass mädchen auf jeden fall sehr trocken
und immer abends sorgen sind auch was
die eigentlich gar nicht angeht wenn
irgendwelche anderen aus der stufe oder
sonst plötzlich in einer beziehung sind
oder ist da so knistert oder wie man es
sagen möchte das ist ja für jedes
mädchen grund genug ein bisschen da mal
rein zum stöbern mit paar freundinnen
darüber zu erzählen aber dass ihr sogar
wissen wie unsere unterhose aussieht mag
ich zu bezweifeln ihr könnt ja mal in
die kommentare schreiben
welche farbe hat meine unterhose gerade
bin gespannt wo kommt zurück ins dorf
da kann ich sagen als junger mann denkt
vielleicht als mädchen so jungs den ist
das scheißegal aber nein wir schauen
auch ab und zu was ihr so für fotos mit
wem kostet oder was ihr so ins netz
treibt natürlich jetzt nicht so krank
wie das einige mädels anstellen tun
aber ein bisschen auch so der nächste
punkt ein mädchen macht mit ihren
freundinnen einen plan die man am besten
seine aufmerksamkeit ergattert und ein
junge macht entweder gar nichts oder
macht einfach drauflos bespricht das
aber nicht los sein kumpel sie begrüßte
vroni kann ich wirklich so gut
vorstellen wenn man ich sag mal so noch
etwas jünger ist 14 15 und damit seine
freundin sitzt heute wie kann ich denn
vorgehen ja wie man jetzt die
aufmerksamkeit ergattert das habe ich
bestimmt irgendwann zu ja als ich sehr
sehr viele jungs mädchen videos gedreht
hat schon ein video gemacht aber das ist
anscheinend an so dass halt viele mädels
sich zusammensetzen und da den
masterplan überlegen
bei uns ist es auch keinen fall so ich
würde sagen hast du dein wellen jungs
früher gesagt so etwas auf die schanzer
ich habe mich verliebt hätte ich auch
nicht und vereint nur aus folgendem
grund wenn man das nämlich gesagt hat
dann konnte man schon so davon ausgehen
soll wenn wenn ich also in die klassiker
oder so
kofler die freunde durch die kst alex
guck mal da ist anteil so voll die
wechselaktion meist so dass es war immer
so bei mir war das immer so deswegen
habe ich irgendwann gar nichts mehr
gesagt natürlich
natürlich auch anders sagen wir mal das
ist dann auch der unterschied dazwischen
also zu freundinnen die unterstützen
nicht wirklich so untereinander
sie sagen ja macht es so schreiben dass
sie das und jungs nutzten fallout und
stellen so schön zu fünft los vor der
ganzen klasse und natürlich auch vor dem
bestimmten mädchen der julia kurzer
story des wahlergebnisses gegen 18 auf
tour
eine extra für im restaurant rennen und
ich war in meinen ganzen jungs da und
dann fangen sie ein angebot für dich
denn irgendwie einfach rausgegangen wie
bislang so oft wie möglich wenn
innerhalb der community
das geht einfach lecker wie immer das
klonen dann wieder gehen
man denkt sich so acht das vergeht
irgendwann ist man aus dem alter raus
dann denkt man nicht mehr so kindes im
kopf nein das ist nicht so auch mit 17
oder 18 und nicht nur so kommen wir zum
nächsten punkt die da ja habt ihr alle
für komische heute früh na da ja noch
nie gehört dass mädchen analysiert jedes
wort was er ihr schreibt oder sagt und
sucht irgendwelche indirekten anleitung
darauf dass er was von i will nur um
sich selber gut gefühlt hatte fasste auf
das ist würde ich mal sagen nicht gut
als ich habe gelernt man muss wirklich
lernen mit der wahrheit umzugehen vor
allem was das angeht nehmen es einfach
so wie es ist entweder es passte das
passt nicht und wenn irgendetwas nicht
passt dann merkt man das ja und dann
muss man nicht versuchen da sind was
gutes reininterpretieren klasse es ist
spät alles rein interpretieren rhein zu
interpretieren das wollte ich sagen und
wenn jungs ist es an sich dann was das
angeht genauso die rein zu
interpretieren dann einfach das gleiche
weil man das halt nicht einfach so hin
möchte so noch ein punkt ebenfalls
natürlich von dem mädchen als mädchen
wartet man immer ab dass der junge mann
schreibt weil man ihn nicht nerven
möchte und man redet 1000 uns über
diesen jungen
kann ich sagen es ist schlecht wenn ihr
den ihn antreibt sondern er mich
antreibt
aber das ist anders rum natürlich
genauso ich mein ich verstehe nicht wie
viele punkte die ihr mir als mädchen
geschickt habe da kann ich nur sagen hey
das ist sagen dass frauen genauso es
gibt natürlich auch andere sachen
aber was das angeht ich finde es ist
wichtig dass man nicht immer den anderen
an schreib ich hab schon so vieles doch
nichts gehört von irgendwelchem freundin
von mir die halt irgendwie einer
beziehung sind oder waren und auch schon
älter sind 18 oder so und immer diese
ständige öl soll ich sie jetzt anfragen
oder schreibt sie mir endlich mal wieder
soweit ist und dass deswegen meiner
meinung nach muss da immer so ein
gewisses gleichgewicht herrschen ja das
ist sehr sehr wichtig so vielleicht war
das waren jetzt ein paar vergleiche von
meiner sicht eher ich jetzt schön
gefunden wenn ich noch ein paar dinge
von anderen jungs aus deren sicht mit
reinnehmen hätte können ist leider nicht
passiert wird mir sehr leid ansonsten
silber und sondern wieder verkürzen
live-video-chat nutzwert und entwickler
web auf jeden fall folgen dann könnt ihr
auch im nächsten video mal ein bisschen
zu beitragen wenn ihr mir nicht folgt
und wir sehen uns ein schönes wochenende